building a culture and I think it's a
culture that will change Venture it's
it's a culture that puts us in their
shoes of the founders or and and because
we walk in there and enable us to really
be of value
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're going to be talking to Aaron
Zucker founder and managing partner at
sapir Venture Partners a pre-seed and
Seed stage fund investing in Israeli
Founders in Israel and in the U.S who
are commercializing deep Tech disappear
operates during mentorship driven model
where the diligence process essentially
builds a relationship that allows
Superior Venture Partners to add
meaningful value Beyond Capital as these
new Ventures create foundations for
long-term growth before founding
Superior Venture Partners Aaron Was a
Serial founder launching and building
startups in Israel and in the US he is a
recovering attorney just like everyone
else's in Israel with an LLB from Hebrew
University in Jerusalem and holds an MBA
from MIT Sloan where he also completed
the entrepreneurship and Innovation
track he is also the executive director
of mass challenge Israel Mass challenge
Israel is the largest accelerator
program in Israel that does not take any
Equity from Founders they are in
non-profit organization with the global
footprint working with over 3 300
experts who mentor and judge the
companies in their core accelerator
competition the mass challenge Israel is
based in Jerusalem from there they have
accelerated over 300 new Ventures who
have gone on to raise over a billion
dollars
[Music]
such a great time over these 20 minutes
20 short minutes but they're going to be
very meaningful
um your your journey is such an an
awesome and inspiring one for so many
different capacities from an
entrepreneurial capacity from a
mentorship capacity investing capacity
volunteering Academia so many different
things to to touch upon it's very
evident
um through also the bio that we just
read to the audience listening here that
you're taking part in so many different
passion passion projects that are also
very much in line with with the business
World
um and and so I'd love for you to help
me just connect the dots a little bit
and we'll start there connect the dots
for me throughout your career what's
been guiding you what are really some of
the big stepping stones that you've
identified as meaningful to your own
sort of personality your own leadership
and let's start from there and then
we'll dive into some of the more
concrete items
so that's a really good question to
start with right because I now that you
kind of got a glimpse of what I've done
there is a common threat right and I
would say the Common Thread is
definitely about helping people
so it's about helping others achieve and
I guess that's kind of like my own
understanding of where I can be most
influential and impactful in the world
myself
to help others realize their dreams I
realize that yeah I may be an optimist
or maybe a realist uh but I'm
necessarily the creative mind enough to
come up with something brand new I'm a
doer I like getting things done but when
I meet people who need help getting
things done
that's what we'll try to do so that's
that's the mentorship that's the
volunteering you were talking about but
it's also been along the road I've had
lots of opportunity at those different
junctures that we all get to to really
be able to pick the people I do it with
and I I feel privileged not that I had
the choice we all have choices but then
I met those people and when I met them
and at the end of the day whether they
know it or not they have been impactful
mentors to me
and so today most of my work is focused
on being that type of person for the
next generation of Founders not
necessarily in age generation wise but
definitely people who are out there
trying to make an impact grow something
new make it big and and have a positive
effect and we can help enable that
through that Journey so that would be
the thread that that's common I'll
happen to give you specific examples
yeah yeah please do please do
so crazy story that that
at the time I couldn't believe was
happening I I had graduated law school
at Hebrew University yeah and as you
know here in Israel you have to do a
year of starch of your internship yep
and because
it's such a competitive field especially
in Israel where you throw it still and
you'll hit a lawyer right everybody here
went to law school
um
you sign up to your internship role
already at the beginning of your second
year out of a four-year program
so you're committed way in advance
before you've alert enough to understand
what you want to do and I had committed
to a firm that actually I was thought I
was going to be working in the space of
startups intellectual property uh
venture capital
and get some experience there and that
firm right when I was graduating from
law school had split up
and the group that was doing all the
work that was interesting to me the
startups of venture capital fundraising
working with Founders didn't take any of
the interns and the other group the
larger group kept all the interns and I
was supposed to be doing work that I
didn't want to do
I was there for three days and I
realized that culturally it was a
terrible thing we were just it was not
going to work out well
and so I went back to the vard
association and I told them that this
isn't a good fit they said you have two
weeks if you can't find an alternative
internship in two weeks then you're
gonna lose the cycle so after four years
of school I'm gonna lose my cycle and
get thrown off track for my career and
it was definitely very very stressful I
interviewed in three places
and one of them it was just by
happenstance they had somebody who was
doing a lot of work in English as you
can tell I have native English and uh
that person was going out and leave they
asked me to kind of step in turned out
to be an amazing experience got to learn
so much met amazing people uh and if I
had not taken the risk of walking away
from the other place and and putting my
career trajectory on hold uh I would
never have met
right what what lesson are you taking
with you from that occurrence
um on you know on a greater level to
your to the rest of your journey because
it sounds like this is a pretty pretty
foundational experience that that gives
you a lot of clarity as to your own sort
of the the different things to
prioritize and and where you want to be
focusing your energies on
so I think I learned a lot of things
from that and and it fits with things I
was doing already before that but
the idea of being bold taking risks
that's at the end of the day what we do
today as investors we're taking that
risk on other people
and in that case I was taking a risk on
myself
similar thing when you and you did the
same thing going to Stanford getting up
and leaving Israel going to learn in the
U.S super expensive right there's a lot
of costs involved whether it's actual
tuition uh or the cost of living I went
with a family
so there was a lot of risk there these
are ties where I'm taking risks on
myself that I'm going to figure it out
that I'm going to be able to leverage
the skills the network that I have in
order to be able to to make myself
successful though defining what success
is obviously at the beginning of the
journey and then where you end up may be
very different and so you also need to
be able to internalize that and
appreciate that and in that regard I
still have been very lucky
I love it how does investing and working
in in the tech industry in general how
does that satisfy a lot of your passions
today and and soon we'll get to the
whole mentorship aspect but you know
you're coming into it from a because a
lot of the things that you're doing are
obviously very you know they're very
um very communal Community Driven a lot
of giving and so I'd like to connect you
know the business world to that through
your eyes
so I I'll actually make a distinction
between business and Tech right so yeah
I think Tech has propelled us forward as
a species right it's true we've been
able to do amazing things and we will
continue to do so and it's accelerating
at a pace that is you know we couldn't
believe it today and I'm sure we're
gonna look back in 10 years and think
that we were slow in dinosaurs and and
that's fascinating to me that fast-paced
things happening you mentioned before
that that I volunteer one of the things
I volunteer is as an EMT yeah yeah so
you're meeting people in crisis and
you're helping them in their greatest
time of need and it could be a very
stressful environment where things have
to get done and you don't want to make
mistakes in people's lives
and actually my father-in-law gave me a
lot of insight around that he said one
of the reasons I continue to do that is
because you can see your impact in a
more immediate way it's it's a shorter
time frame when you're investing in
super early stage companies it could be
a decade before you see their returns
before you can see even the impact and
results think of how many pivots and
funding rounds and the economy going up
and down there are so many challenges
they still need to overcome
and so I do love that right because
that's part of you have to be able to
love the journey as well and so the key
to having a great journey is the people
that you do that you go on that Journey
on with and that's what we're asking
Founders to do essentially they're we're
asking them to let us join them on their
journey in a small way we're going to
help we're gonna carry the load we're
going to be there but at some point we
may not be relevant and we've had
multiple companies many companies our
portfolio that God answer is their a
their B their C at that point we're
early States we're pretty seed that's
the world we know those are the
companies we've built
um and then we've handed them off and
that's what we do now with our
investments as well
interesting so going now to quickly the
foundation of superior Venture Partners
tell me a little bit about that story
what led to that and a little bit about
the strategy and then we're going to
focus on mentorship
so sapir spun out of my angel activity
uh where I had started uh I as an angel
fund basically people who had investing
with us as Founders as entrepreneurs uh
had made some money with us not a lot
and uh were willing to give me another
chance while I was seeing these amazing
opportunities amazing Founders and
already very small checks
but when I looked back after a couple of
years of doing that we had 12 companies
in the portfolio and they were doing
pretty well uh some are still doing very
well and I was thinking about what's
next I had just kind of transitioned out
in one company we had sold another
startup uh gen 9 that we had built in
Boston and it was the right time for
what's next another company go all in on
investing and I was suggested by
somebody with some relatively deep
pocket that I cook full time at the
investing and this was the end of 2016
beginning of 2017 where a lot of the
microbees these that we know today were
popping up
um and starting to get traction the ones
who were really early started to get
bigger and there was so much happen and
so I stopped and I said you know what
why do I need another venture capital
what do I add this app assistant
and I went and built a pitch deck for
myself and then use the pitch my Venture
partners and then investors but first a
debt for myself and just looking at the
ecosystem looking at the math where do
we add value why what's the
justification for us to exist and the
answer actually came to me from a very
specific story so we were very early uh
the first Equity round in tomorrow I O
at the time they were climate cell three
Israeli Founders in Boston at Harvard
and MIT
great great great guys and I met them
through the MIT Network and I was
spending time with them working on their
decks go to market pricing amazing model
I love the company not with the guys
when I was traveling regularly to Boston
I'd spend some of my time with them uh
they're still great friends today and I
pulled them it to speak as guest
speakers but at the time they were going
through that Equity round and and Shimon
CEO and I were talking and telling me
about his debate right does he take
money from a less known BC would I love
the partners did they take money from a
very well-known BC where they didn't
think the cultural fit was as good they
had a bunch of angels that could be
strategic they couldn't take everybody
what do you do
and it was just thinking through it with
them and then they invited me to join
that route which was an amazing
opportunity
and we're very glad that we did and we
wish we had more to put in at that time
um but when I thought about it
afterwards and I was thinking about that
hey
we clearly added some value there right
we had value to add from our experience
to kind of Mentor them which is why we
call it mentorship driven investing and
it is a hard transition from being a
Founder an entrepreneur somebody who
gets things done an executive who makes
things happen to being the cheerleader
the support
for these founders and that was
definitely hard but that's where it kind
of hinged on this mentorship driven
investing more only or we can add value
and actually our diligence process is
creating that mentorship so we try to
add value before we even invest Capital
which means we're working with Founders
for a longer period of time just to give
you an anecdote we make no new
investments in 2021 with the craziness
of what was happening with nine days to
terms and two weeks to close that
doesn't work for our mod and so we're
definitely missed on some companies but
we're meeting companies today who are
able to get in some Capital debt and now
realize that they need helpful Capital
what used to be called smart capital I
don't think we're that smart but we do
try to be helpful and we're getting in
on deals today that have now been
de-risked a little bit with capital from
2021 and now we can invest in 2022 and
build on that to work with these
Founders taken to the next phase
especially in the challenging markets
that we're navigating today
wow okay so tell me just a little bit
about the mentorship process that you
work with the founders how do you build
that trust what is that obviously it's
going to be it's going to be a different
process for everybody but from an
entrepreneur's perspective what well
when you talk to me about you know
potential mentorship that I could be
getting as a young entrepreneur and
helpful mentorship what does that look
like for me what is the relationship
that I'm going to be experiencing myself
throughout you know both the initial
phase of getting to know each other as
well as a little bit later on
foreign
I guess there's two phases uh or two
different paths one is if we're the lead
investor and one if we're not the
leading investor so for not the lead
investor obviously we want the lead to
be somebody we trust and we know and I
think we've built a nice brand in the in
the ecosystem where we're invited into
certain rounds and then they know where
we're specifically can add value and
that'll be where most of our
conversation is around it could be
around the tech developments around the
process of spinning out of a university
lab it could be
it could be around the Golden Market up
to be about hiring
um that's very specific so we can we'll
go in and we'll just spend time with the
founders like any investor does we'll
get to know them we'll get to see how
they think and if we'll evaluate can't
we really be helpful to them both as far
as the personal connection and as far as
the specific need we're being asked to
contribute up
when were the lead which we definitely
like to do what we can't always do uh
when we're the lead it's it's much much
closer relationship so with companies
that we sit on boards we speak to the
CEOs the founders every week we block
off an hour of time and we tell them
this is your time to talk to us about
whatever you want you want to just vent
you want to talk politics you want to
tell me what's happening in your family
that's fine because my goals there is to
be
a distressing element
because they are CEOs they're Founders
they have a lot to juggle and the way to
build that is by getting to know how
they think and for them to get to know
how we think and that takes time and so
we'll often spend a lot of time thinking
about their technology development plan
their team development plan and their
financial plan not because we care about
the details and we don't know how to
build their technology and their
business better than they do it's just
because that allows us to get into Their
fines and understand how they think to
get to understand their assumptions
challenge their assumptions see how they
respond and how we interact right so if
we think about it we're trying to be
part of the team and in order to have
that team be effective we need to get to
that period of storming where we're not
in a Range so that we can get to that
norming and figure out how we will work
together even though we're not in
agreement that sounds a little extreme
and it does happen
but it actually ends up being really
really powerful relationships and I
could say across 30 companies we've
invested in I feel like we've only
failed at that once
wow I mean at the end it's a I mean a
lot of the things that you were talking
about you know they may sound
um adversarial to an entrepreneur's
process but obviously they're exactly
what this whole process is about you you
started this conversation you're talking
about the analogy of you know the early
stage companies sometimes it takes a
decade to see the results and you make
endless pivots along the ways and you
have to navigate through different
Market structures we're seeing that now
and and to the end being able to live in
this disagreement reality but in a
fruitful way where a foundation of trust
was built and it sounds like you're
prioritizing that Foundation of trust to
be a Cornerstone of the due diligence
process that's what's going to allow a
group of great thinkers to think
together challenge assumptions and and
become better together so I can
definitely see why you know the the the
this mentorship driven investing is a
big part of your own life
I mean how it's some I would sum it up
you know founder Collective I think said
it best and and I I would love to steal
their tagline but I can't but they want
to be the investors that they wish they
had when they were Founders and that's
definitely who we want to be uh we've
been in the trenches we've had great
investors we were very lucky with some
of our investors uh who taught us a lot
taught me personally a lot
um and that's who we want to be for them
but in order to do that if you just are
all you know hyped and fluff and it's
all good like we saw last year it's
going to be very hard to work together
in the trenches when times get tough and
ties get tough we've had multiple
companies now where the founders were
the ones that did not get along and
being able to come in and step in and be
that third party to mitigate to kind of
realign them on the vision that brought
them together in the first place and
overcome whatever challenges or figure
out a way to break apart evitably and
move forward so the company doesn't
suffer is is a valuable thing to to be
able to do and not every investor can do
that
right I mean that makes a lot of sense
if you're looking today at the the
vision that you hold for for yourself
for Superior Venture partners for
mentorship driven investing what is sort
of the vision that you hold that you're
working towards
so ultimately it's a question we get a
lot from potential LPS NLP yeah uh about
how do we scale because right we're not
we're not a fund believe ourselves as a
firm we're building a culture and I
think it's a culture that will change
Venture it's it's a culture that puts us
in their shoes so the founders or and
and because we walk in there and enable
us to really be of value
um it also means that we we often invest
in what I would say are underrepresented
founders
right so think about in Israel where
where Founders are coming from we have a
challenge not enough companies are
getting spun out of the universities
they're coming out of the IDF uh elite
units intelligence units they're coming
out of other large tech companies that
they spin out of and go do their own
thing there's a lot less coming off of
Campus where we're very active but also
in the US people tend to forget that
Israeli Founders in the US even if they
went to Harvard and MIT in Stanford
they're still immigrants and they're
still going to be dealing with a lot of
challenges that the immigrants go
through even as simple as understanding
the local culture and how to engage with
the market how to get to your customer
and understand what the customer is
saying so you can build a solution for
their problem
we want to be that bridge and continue
to do that so as a firm we hope to be
able to grow with additional people uh
hopefully in the future it'll be
Founders that we invested in that will
have had success so we'll come back into
the fold we already do that now and fun
too we've added on uh three founder
advisors so we invested in early on and
are now advising the the new Founders we
invest in so it's it's been a great
journey so far but we really are just at
the beginning and we hope to really
change the culture specifically around
Israelis and in its
fantastic this is awesome Aaron this was
such a such a fun experience for me to
get into your own your own journey and
and I can start connecting the dots 20
minutes is not enough but it's it's
becoming clearly evident how Community
mentorship helping people in when they
when they when in the time that they
need it and how these different
activities if you're a part of we didn't
even touch on the fact that you're
executive director and mass challenges
are all today
um so so it's all coming together sounds
like the founders that you're backing
are very lucky to have you as a part of
their family and and so uh wishing you
best of luck with with Superior as as a
firm with culture and creating
differentiation with culture and and
definitely your work with
underrepresented Founders campuses Etc
so again thank you for being here
looking forward to sharing this and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you very much Michael this was fun
and they even realize 20 minutes went
past I'm telling you that's how it is
thank you Aaron
[Music]